the others juices flying around do you
like basketball er no I like basketball
I don't I don't I don't keep up with it
[Music]
like a football NASCAR yeah all the
homies watch basketball yeah so [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I like I'm I'm into it like not
even at my own will like is there just
by association all the homies friends
I don't homies play to km yeah all of
this by association I'm never talking
about it briefly before but what you
were saying that you just got into
playing skate three so yeah on the
original Xbox Xbox one so yeah they came
out with a version that's like backwards
compatible so you can play it either on
Xbox one or two 360 that's crazy I wish
they would start I heard that they were
just came out they just released the
original Tony Hawk - yes so there that
was turning Tony Hawk's birthday he
announced the the the remaster so dude I
don't think I don't think I even played
the original really Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater
I remember playing one of them I
remember playing the one where you're in
Tampa well you can literally state the
[ __ ] spot the [ __ ] spaceship yeah
the skate park it's him
they had the [ __ ] the Odyssey in it
didn't it bro Bowl in there - yeah yeah
yeah in the original it was one of them
it was one of them but yeah dude that's
it's so cool cuz like I feel like now
like skating has come and so like full
force back around bro cuz like there was
a there was a span of time when I wasn't
into skating you know I'm saying like I
felt like you know I'm saying I I felt
like that wasn't part of me anymore just
because I wasn't like physically
skateboarding right so like I would've
felt like a poser like you know I'm Sam
but I mean you can check the receipts
man I said I I was really skating you
know saying so now it's just I'm
I'm getting influenced from all that
[ __ ] but that doesn't necessarily mean I
got a if I can be out here skating 20
plays on because I don't get your not
like you know hitting handrails or
skating at the park every day doesn't
mean you can't appreciate the culture
and take something from it
yeah because even if you're just like on
the outside of it like contributing you
know you need music to escape to yeah
people need photographers for a
skateboard you need videographers need
designers it isn't just about the act of
skateboarding it's more of like a
mindset and a culture that can
contribute to and take something away
from into this day man like I'll know I
made it when like a pro skateboarder
uses my song for their does it happened
come and be like a clip on Thrasher I
saw the worst thing on Instagram
yesterday
this dude Italia for Arab like one of
like top-five pro surfers how they call
whole surf section to a Marilyn Manson
song and it was the worst thing I've
ever seen in my life yeah definitely not
go no thing about a surf part I'm trying
to hear something like groovy like I
don't know I'm not trying to like listen
to some like crazy like hardcore people
me and him just got back into surfing
recently yeah same thing that you fall
out for so long that you know it was a
big part of who you were and who what
inspired you to be who you are today
mm-hmm and he gets so caught up in like
the day-to-day of just trying to like
forge your path as a creative and
survive that you those things kind of
fall off yeah but once you get
comfortable and I through it a little
bit you can look back and like oh yeah I
did like doing that and that did help me
get here yeah man it's part of you man
like like I said dude like I there was
one point where I feel like man like
this isn't like I don't skate no more
like you know I'm saying like I feel
like I couldn't appreciate skateboarding
as much as I wanted to at some point but
comes back around you you realize you
know the love that you have for it like
damn like you know looking through a
bunch of my old skate videos like I
guess a bunch of like Vimeo
from like oh nine yeah way you know I'm
Sam mm yeah we got so many of those -
yeah you just have to allow your
relationship to evolve with it and it
can't just be fixed on what it was at
that certain point in your life yeah
yeah you're totally right man it's
surfing hard yeah it's definitely hard
because I feel like some people do make
it really easy it's like one of those
things were like you can bring a
different mindset to it now like like
back in the day like I never used to
even think about it I just was obsessed
with doing it like we were just obsessed
with going to travel to find amazing
waves what you did and just go and just
love doing it like I never actually
tried to be good or get better but I
feel like now like the part of my life
that I'm in now like I can actually
focus on it and actually try to learn
stuff and like improve techniques and
like bring my evolution of my brain
apply that to surfing like how I do
everything else yeah yeah a few times
like bro anytime I've seen like a
surfing video it's out in Cali or like
Hawaii
yeah somewhere like that all crazy
remote places oh yeah
South Africa West or West the west coast
outfit yeah I want to try to learn how
to surf each other this is the wall this
is the time of year where we hit a
hurricane swells in Florida yeah dude I
totally forgot about hurricane season
mm-hmm they're saying this is going to
be like the gnarliest hurricane season
in a long time just wait till phase
phase three and four of 2020 just got
through all my Corona liquor so now I
gotta go get some hurricane liquor we're
gonna get pummeled by hurricanes for the
next three months and then the UFOs are
gonna come around November or December
yeah at the very end of 2020 arrow is
just gonna be like is just gonna be like
i'ma head out later
we're on [ __ ] airplane mode how is
2020 starting out for you before
everything um hit the fan really are so
2020 for me I'm killing this food right
yeah kill it man it's making me sweat
those eggs in there I've been dipping
eggs in the juice yeah juicy eggs yeah
beginning of 2020 for me I was just
releasing the big baby
ernhardt yeah so dude my mindset was
both righto full throttle I'm about to
drop this album the beer is coming out
because the beer came out the same day
Thursday night so the album came out
that night I believe so I was just Gared
up ready to go for the year man and like
I think Jenni way January was pretty
good and then I think Thank You Man
Jenni Way was pretty good and then I
think the first thing that like really
[ __ ] with everybody is like [ __ ] up
everybody his Co he dude yeah that was
like later I was like late January man
and I think after that like 2020s just
it was just like a domino effect dude
yeah I feel like it was the energy it
might have been just you know I believe
in the law of attraction and just you
know we've been on a slippery slope ever
since energy and you know [ __ ] like that
dude and you know if you think it just
brought the collective human will down
I'm Co dude and like you know the corona
[ __ ] came and then everything else but I
feel like you know we got to go through
the bad to get to the good you know I'm
saying at the same time so I got to look
at it as a you know glass halfway
halfway for us then you know so a lot of
people think you know I'm saying like
the year is just gonna end like [ __ ] but
I mean it's we still got six months left
man six months can change your life man
like who knows
might be if I can out of here if I can
famous as [ __ ] you know I'm saying
entity year like who knows what do you
what are you trying to do well what is
you do you have like a goal for one year
5 years 10 years like what do you want
to do with your life in the next one to
five years I wouldn't be entrepreneur
man like entrepreneur definitely like
music is always gonna be like forefront
passion like I'm like an artist first
rapper first you know I'm saying this
got me my talent rapping got me into you
know what I'm doing now so I'm always be
rapping but I do want to eventually like
you know kind of branch off and just
create content along the lines of you
know just like food [ __ ] and like just I
don't know like funny [ __ ] man like like
same thing Andrews doing you know not
like like interviewer no like that but
just having like a platform where I can
just do a bunch of like silly [ __ ] you
know I'm saying and just leave the music
should well that's you know I mean the
music is always there and that was the
launching pad for right who expressions
right yeah man cuz like I don't want to
be like my 30s you know I'm saying
checking the AC because it's a million
degrees in here oh so this is big baby
scumbag that's Curtis Curtis would you
want some crab era Bud Light yeah we got
Bud Light crab legs you're welcome we
got sausage you know why claw corn corn
can't help you there alright we go to
timeout and check for you though
Pinellas parks like 20 minutes away for
me yes
[Laughter]